fossils are more widespread than you may
realize as a boy charles darwin used to
spend a lot of time in the outdoors he
was an avid hunter and fisherman
it may be because of that background
that when he went to college he left
medical studies but enthusiastically
embraced biology and then geology in a
famous letter to his sister in april
1834 he wrote
there is nothing like geology the
pleasure of the first days partridge
shooting or the first days hunting
cannot be compared to finding a fine
group of fossil bones which tell their
story of former times with almost a
living tongue
that's what happens an interest in the
outdoors and collecting becomes a
passion for geology and paleontology
could that happen to you i hope so at
least a little
and then who knows
fossil collecting is something that
everyone can do it's a great way to get
out to enjoy nature and to learn about
the geology around you
with a little bit of knowledge about
what fossils are and we talked about
that in the previous lecture
and a little insight into the geologic
occurrences of fossils you can be
collecting in no time
after all humans have been collecting
wondering about and enjoying fossils for
most of recorded history
even before that neanderthals used to
place fossils around burial sites the
reason of course is unknown but it
certainly is symbolic of the immortality
of preservation
it took a long time for people to
appreciate exactly what fossils were and
why they were important
initially people tried to explain
fossils with legends
ammonites were called snake stones in
ireland and thought to be the snakes
driven away by saint patrick
here
is a snakestone
can you imagine its head coming out of
the shell
this is a small ammonite a relative of
squid the star-like forms of crinoids
and corals
were called star stones
and believed to have fallen from the sky
here's a coral
can you see the stars
these of course are colonial animals
aristotle suggested that fossil fish
were animals that had lived in the past
but his theory was that they had swam in
cracks in rocks and at some point were
stranded there
in the mid 1600s nicolo steno the
founder of modern stratigraphy
recognized that fossil sharks teeth were
the remnants of sharks very similar to
those of today
but prior to his studies people
considered sharks teeth to be the
tongues of dragons or snakes
now we know that fossils are evidence of
past life
whether it's a part of the animal or
evidence that the animal existed this
evidence is preserved in the rock record
fossil collecting can enable you to
reconstruct what animals or plants lived
in the past it's a lot of fun it's
really informative and i would argue
it's pretty exciting when you come
across a well-preserved fossil
also now that you have learned about
sediments sedimentary environments and
types of fossils that are preserved it's
not a difficult process to go do some
pretty good fossil collecting
what's different is you'll spend more
time turning over the rocks you see and
maybe more time scrambling up and down
slopes since that's where fossils are
more likely to have come to the surface
it's also important to know about
collecting
access to collecting areas and ownership
so fossil hunting is an advanced sort of
rock collecting
one very famous tyrannosaur fossil is
named sue is by several measures the
most well-preserved tyrannosaurus in the
world
a lot of people also know that it is the
most expensive dinosaur ever purchased
with a purchase price of over 8 million
but its history is to say the least
complicated an award-winning documentary
about it called dinosaur 13 was made in
2014.
a group of scientists from a private
firm had obtained permission to collect
fossils in western south dakota
the story goes that the collecting
season was almost over and several
samples of dinosaurs had been collected
and the group was close to wrapping up
a flat tire on one of the vehicles
resulted in the group splitting up and
one staying behind with a car with a
flat
that paleontologist sue hendrickson
decided to do some checking around in
places the group had not studied
and she found some of the remains of the
tyrannosaur
it was recognized quickly that this was
a great find the skeleton was excavated
and taken back to the group's lab
once word got out how special the
tyrannosaur fossil was
people became interested
the landowner who had given them
permission to collect
raised questions about the process
additional complications included the
fact that the tyrannosaur was found on
tribal lands the department of the
interior claimed that it was land under
their trust
so to suffice it to say
discussions ensued
these discussions ultimately resulted in
the fbi and south dakota national guard
raiding the labs where the fossil was
being analyzed and a long political and
legal battle began
so the moral of the story is to make
sure that when you collect fossils
you're doing it on land where you have
legal access and have permission to
collect
they are not the same thing
in the u.s legal system contrary to
common perception
all rocks minerals and fossils are
treated as being owned or possessed by
some person or entity
of course if you own the land you are
allowed to keep fossils you might
collect
if you don't own the property you have
to check with who does and what you
might need to do to gain permission to
collect
one way to ensure that your collecting
is legal is to ask either private
landowners or public land managers
many places especially federal lands
restrict fossil collecting to
invertebrates
you're often not allowed to collect
vertebrate fossils
national parks in general do not allow
the collection of fossils at all
but in the case of national forests
collecting invertebrate fossils is
sometimes possible
make sure you check and if required get
a permit
in many states there are designated
fossil hunting localities there are
designated state preserves in new jersey
ohio maryland texas pennsylvania
california and colorado where you can
collect
there are frequently restrictions based
on what you're going to do with your
fossils if the fossils you collect are
for personal non-commercial use you can
keep them
sometimes tensions can run a little high
when it comes to fossil collection if
the sale of those fossils is involved
not only do you encounter ownership
issues but there's also the question of
the scientific use of the fossils
there are a variety of famous and
wealthy individuals who collect fossils
on face value that's great and interest
in fossils is completely understandable
but sometimes sales to private buyers
will bypass opportunities for scientific
analysis
there are a lot of fossils in private
hands that have never been studied by
scientists
that's viewed as problematic by the
scientific community
yes it's certainly true that in most
cases fossils and private hands do not
contribute to the broader body of
scientific knowledge
but in a rare case it would be handy to
have a paleontologist study it
so to sum up before you go fossil
collecting you're going to find out who
owns land
whether or not fossil collecting is
permitted and if you need a permit
checking beforehand may save you a lot
of headaches
if you are collecting fossils let
scientists know about it
your state geologic survey is a good
place to start when you want to let
someone know what you found
they might also give you some advice
about what you found and where you can
do additional collecting
a rule of thumb is that if you find
something but don't know what it is
please
show it to a scientist
when getting ready for fossil collecting
you go through the same organizational
procedures as with any field work you'll
need water multiple ways of locating
yourself
maps gps cell phone
your field book and a camera
specifically for fossil hunting you need
tools to help you excavate hammer pick
shovel
smaller tools to pick away matrix or
chisel apart bedding planes
sample bags something to wrap your
fossils in
and marking pens to label your specimens
a camera is really important for fossil
collecting you want to take pictures of
the outcrop right where you found the
fossils
frequently you will encounter fossils
you won't be able to remove without
damaging so a picture will provide a
record of the important finds
i can't emphasize enough that there are
some outcrops that you shouldn't take a
hammer to
there is nothing more irritating than
knowing the location of a great fossil
only to return to it with students to
find that someone's destroyed it in an
attempt to remove it
a photo
is a great way to collect fossils
at some fossil localities weathering and
erosion will separate the fossils from
the rocks that they occur in
when you collect fossils along a river
cut or a wave cut most of the collecting
is done at the bottom of the bank where
the wave action or running water and
rain will loosen up the rock or sediment
that contains the fossil
if the fossil is made out of resistant
material it will fall out of the
sediment or rock in fairly good shape
at other localities fossils are still
embedded in the geologic unit
in those cases you have to remove the
rock material together with the fossil
i have to warn you it's a rookie mistake
to try and trim the fossil out of the
rock in the field more fossils get
damaged that way
take a chunk of the rock that has the
fossil in it you can do the detail
trimming called preparation
back at home
this shark tooth was left in the rock
but polished for presentation
can you see the cracks in it
it certainly would have been broken if
you tried to remove it here the rock
becomes part of the display
as well as the fossil
at home you will have different tools a
sink to work in time and comfortable
working conditions
the finished or prepared fossils will be
much better
before you go fossil hunting let someone
know where you will be and when you'll
be there maybe leave both a map and a
description of the geologic units you're
looking for you should always do field
work with someone else for a number of
reasons i've outlined those in lecture
three
but on top of that leaving a description
of your destination and collecting plans
is just an easy thing to do to ensure
that you can be located in emergency
again i understand that cell phones can
be very handy for a wide variety of
needs but i have never learned to trust
them mainly because i've spent a lot of
time in places that cell phones don't
have coverage
okay you're ready
you have all the stuff that you need for
fieldwork you've got a friend who is
also interested in collecting fossils
and you've let people know where you'll
be
the big question is where do you go it's
a good question
finding fossil localities isn't always
easy
as i mentioned in many states there are
designated fossil hunting localities
here's a map of a few of the good ones
in the u.s
calvert cliffs in maryland is a place
where you can walk along the chesapeake
bay and collect sharks teeth
in freehold new jersey an hour drive
from new york city the big brook fossil
locality exposes cretaceous age shark
teeth
and mosasaur teeth
in ohio caesar creek state park in
waynesville has ordovician aged
trilobites and brachiopods that you can
collect
the list goes on
for more locations to visit try geologic
organizations in your state
these might include the state geologic
survey a local geologic society or a
university nearby
some geological organizations like the
geological society of minnesota lead
field trips to well-known collecting
sites
and some lesser-known places
you can also check out opportunities to
collect fossils with the help of
academics or professional fossil guides
there are some programs run by private
firms and universities where you can
sign up and participate in a fossil
excavation
in most cases these are large-scale
and long-standing enterprises
that will involve
very careful preservation of vertebrate
fossils
you get a great introduction to the
science of paleontology but you don't
get to keep the fossils
if keeping fossils is not important to
you
these can be great experiences
there are also commercial fossil
expeditions where you do keep fossils
and all of them can be found pretty
easily on the web in wyoming there are
guides that will take you to the famous
18-inch layer of the green river
formation
in florida guides will help you screen
for mammoth teeth buried in the river
sediments of the peace river
in montana's hell creek formation you
can look for dinosaur bones in oklahoma
you can collect trilobites
the right fossil hunting guide will
ensure your safety your permit to
collect and they'll identify the fossils
you find
in many cases the guides will have an
association with a university
these are good ones to seek out if you
happen to find an important fossil they
will have you turn it over to the
scientific community
they tell you that in advance but
frequently they might have a nice fossil
that they can trade for yours
overwhelmingly the fossils collected at
these more commercial sites are ones you
can keep and the guide will make sure
that collecting is done thoughtfully and
conscientiously
you can find fossil expedition and
guides on the web
blogs and personal websites will provide
some indication of how good the fossil
hunting experience was
another way to find guides is to go to a
mineral gym and fossil show
look around these exhibits if you see a
fossil that interests you
the seller might know if guides can lead
you to the collection sites in many
cases the person displaying and selling
the fossils is the person that can take
you
start a conversation ask questions learn
about the fossil the fossil locality and
the collector you may end up in some
interesting places with some interesting
fossils
in the beginning though most people just
want to go out and look for fossils
maybe if they enjoy their initial
experience they will go on a guided
expedition later but for now say you
just want to look around that's how most
people get started so where do you go
it turns out that there is a lot of
literature about local geologic
exposures many states will have either
websites or brochures about collecting
fossils in the state
localities might be a designated park
but they can also be just a road cut a
place where highway excavations have
exposed fossil fuels rocks
there is also a series of books called
roadside geology these books explain the
geology that you see while driving along
roads in individual states
they also point out where fossils can be
found along the roadside
there are dozens of roadside geology
type books or something like them that
are commercially available guides to the
local geology and they will indicate
where fossils can be found
i have to say here that you do have to
proceed with a little bit of caution
when using fossil pamphlets and roadside
guides
sometimes access and permission to
collect changes since the publication of
a reference you might have
it might be handy to see if you're still
allowed to collect its sites you've read
about
it also is important to always remember
that roadside collecting means you will
be close to traffic
make sure your car is off the road that
you and your car are visible to oncoming
traffic
you also have to be sure that it's legal
to stop on that particular road you
don't want the hassle of a citation
always be sure that you are very careful
to avoid interactions with moving
vehicles
please please be safe along roadsides it
is really fun to collect fossils and
it's great to get excited about them but
safety first always
if it looks safe and it looks like the
right type of rocks then walk along the
base of the outcrop what you're looking
for is fossils that may have eroded out
of the outcrop during rainstorms an
especially good time to check them out
is after a rainstorm or soon after
spring snow melt
but a recent rain also makes rocks
slippery
in south dakota there's a bentonite
volcanic ash that holds so much water
and gets so very slippery on one field
trip a few of the students simply became
obsessed with climbing up the slippery
slope
yes there was the teddy roosevelt
petrified forest to see on the other
side
but the end result was a mud covering
from head to boot
okay so you've collected anything that's
washed out and the outcrop seems safe
walk up a little bit to see if any
fossils are loose on the slope or still
embedded in the rocks
field safety is a must for example
be careful of shifting rocks around as
you search
rocks are hard you don't want to
dislodge anything that's big enough to
hurt you or your field partner you also
don't want to get knocked off balance
you also have to remember that there can
be critters who have made a happy home
under rocks and in spaces between them
some of them don't like to be disturbed
don't stick your hand into cracks
when you're moving rocks use your hammer
not your hand
keep an eye out for fossils and living
things
so now we're looking at the rocks it
turns out that a lot of times you can
predict from the rock type what you
might find
especially if you know the age of the
rock
i bet you can tell me right now what
fossils go with what rock type you want
to try
say you're at an outcrop of shale
slopes will be gentle and there will be
loose sediment on the slope
sometimes the upper layer of material
will crumble beneath your feet
it might be calcareous it might not be
where is a shell deposited
well it's a fine-grained sediment so
that means fairly low energy
what would have lived in that
environment
most commonly shales especially
calcareous shells
are deposited in deeper water of seas
that covered the continental u.s
depending on age of the rock you might
find trilobites brachiopods or mollusks
these devonian age brachiopods from
illinois are hard enough to survive
being washed out as small shells
but these cretaceous pectin shells had
to be cleaned pretty carefully
trilobites are an arthropod that
periodically shed its outer heart part
often those discarded parts are found on
sediment bedding planes you'll have to
split the shale layers open to see if
there's anything in it
look at this bedding plane these are
devonian-aged trilobite remains from
upstate new york
if the shale is cretaceous age and
deposited in the seaway that existed
from texas up to winnipeg you might find
sharks teeth fish bones or the shells of
bivalves
all of those fossils i just mentioned
trilobites and brachiopods from the
paleozoic and sharks teeth and fossil
fish bones from the mesozoic are common
fossils found throughout the united
states
are all shales the same of course not
i've mentioned the green river shale
which is a black shale that was
deposited in anoxic lake environments
in black shales you can find fish bones
leaves insects and even vertebrates but
usually black shale fossil localities
are well known
here's an early mesozoic starfish from
italy that was preserved in a black
shale
how about sandstone what would you find
in there
well think about sandstone it is a high
energy environment where sand has been
transported and deposited by fairly
rapidly moving wind rivers or waves
wind-blown saiyans are notoriously
scarce of fossils if you encounter a
sandstone enjoy the intricate
sedimentary structures and the
sedimentology of the ultrapure sands
and don't worry about fossils
rivers are also high energy yet you do
find fossils of animals that have been
rapidly buried the complication is that
water action will destroy fragile
components and scatter the more robust
ones of course dinosaur fossils are
found in association with river deposits
in the west
when studying river sediments remember
that in most cases you can't collect
vertebrate fossils the exception is
teeth or disarticulated bones of
mammoths or horses that show up in
gravel pits or reworked river deposits
like the peace river in florida
those are great fun to find and collect
most of the fossils that you find in
sandstones are associated with
shorelines again throughout north
america the paleozoic was a time of
shallow seas with changing shoreline
positions in a lot of places you can
collect fossils in finer grains
sandstones or silt stones the fossils
might include brachiopods trilobites and
an occasional fish fossil
here are myoscene aged fish from
shark-tooth hill in california preserved
in a fine sand
more frequently you find trace fossils
in fine sands again
these are tracks or trails or
impressions left behind long ago
let's try one more
say your outcrop is a limestone
in a lot of cases the limestone will be
resistant especially in drier portions
of the country so that means in a lot of
cases limestones are cliff formers
slopes will be steep and the rocks will
be resistant
be careful on steep slopes
what environment did the limestone form
in shallow seas right
envision your favorite coral reef today
in a lot of cases that's where
limestones were deposited in the past
so what will you find
the short answer is a lot of things
brachiopods trilobites and coral of all
varieties depending on the age of the
rock
here's a group of stromatolite towers
this is a half a billion year old fossil
found in a field stone
some sandy limestones will have
well-preserved algal fossils called
stromatolites in precambrian and
cambrian rocks stromatolites make up a
significant portion of the limestones
and are considered to be one of the main
sources of free oxygen in our atmosphere
limestones can also hold cephalopods and
ammonites shelled relatives of octopus
and squid
here's an example of an early paleozoic
cephalopod from winnipeg canada it came
out of a rock quarry and so the rock
quarry sliced these things in half you
can see it beginning here
and extending to here
it was a long thin shell
the list goes on
now you know what you're looking for the
next question is what do you actually
see
the answer is decidedly not anything
that looks like what you've seen in
books
there are lots of fossils but only a few
that are what are called a trophy fossil
the fossils you see in books are both
rare and painstakingly prepared before
being photographed
that's not what you're gonna find in the
field
fossil collectors frequently use the
term fossil hunting to describe the
locating and collecting of fossils
i am not a hunter and i know little
about hunting but i get the point of the
analogy it takes care and preparation
and knowledge and commitment to find
fossils
what you want to look for are objects
that look different from the surrounding
rock a different color a different shape
or a different way the rock is broken
fossils are preserved in every
orientation so you might be looking at
just the edge of the fossil
fossils get folded up or broken or
squished during deposition
you have to be patient you have to get
your eye in for some people it will come
quickly for others it takes time
it definitely helps to have seen what
fossils look like in the field rather
than pictures from a textbook
ultimately
it comes down to observing thoughtfully
rather than just looking
i think most people can do it if they
try
so what do you do when you see a fossil
well if it's loose you pick it up
decide what it is and put it in the
sample bag
you might wrap it up in tissue or a
napkin so it doesn't break
if it's in a limestone you have to make
some decisions
limestone because it is hard is
difficult to collect fossils from
especially when you're just beginning
the tendency is to try and remove only
the fossil from the outcrop
that's a mistake you should either take
photos and leave the fossil there or
take the fossil with a great deal of
matrix around it
when you get back home you can use a
variety of tools
brushes are perfect for removing a small
amount of material
small picks
like a dental pick
can be used to scrape away
more resistant rock
a little bit of water
can help soften up the process
and may make
removal easier
a dremel type tool will help you
physically remove the surrounding matrix
you can also
if you want resort to a little bit more
aggressive practices
i can remove
some of this matrix
from the cephalopod i don't want to do
too much more
some folks use a weak acid like vinegar
to clean up the fossil by dissolving the
cement in the matrix
that's the process called preparation
you may also need a little epoxy if your
fossil broke somewhere along the line
but in most cases it really is just fine
if you just lay out your fossils on a
board
and remember to label location you
collected at and when you collected it
so that's fossil collecting just
remember
stay safe and be careful about where you
collect and get permission if it's
needed
if you think about what you're doing and
what it means in terms of geologic
history i think you'll enjoy fossil
hunting
even if the outcrop you're looking at
turns out not to have fossils that's
okay
on the plus side you're still outside
and you are still doing geology what's
better than that
as many fossil collectors say
good hunting